so my friend my good friend anthony
jeselnik was just here and he made a
very interesting comment about my outfit
let's take a look in case you missed it
you're dressed like
like you're you're the ceo of a pumpkin
patch
you know he jokes but it's it's very
hard to be the ceo of a pumpkin patch
i had to lay off 10 000 scarecrows
oh boy last quarter alone that is a
that's a great ceo of a pumpkin patch
joke i'm going to stand behind that so
right after we did that we actually got
some fan art can we see the fan art this
is almost while it was airing
which is great this is by derrick
o'pearl isn't that fun
so if you guys have any fan art that you
want to see perhaps on the show tweet it
to pete holmes show and that's not all
actually save the fun part here for the
end uh this is uh we like doing fun
stuff towards the end of the show where
most people have changed the channel
this beautiful valuable picture of me
right here that skyler gray he did he
actually said we can give it away so
send us some fan art we're going to pick
our favorite and send you this one of a
kind skylar gray painting which i think
is pretty great go to petehomes.com for
more details pretty good thanks to
skylar gray you can follow him on
instagram at skyler grace street art
that is our show thank you nick crowe
thank you good night